طبعا حلف شمال الاطلسي وفنلندا كلاهما او
يعيش لحظات تاريخيه اليوم في غضون الظهر
يعني بعد ساعات قليله
ستقدم فنلندا
اتفاقيه العضويه مع التوقعات ومسابقه
البرلمانات كافه الدول الاعضاء الثلاثين
الى
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لماذا لان
الولايات المتحده هي التي تحتفظ بمعاهده
انشاء الحلف في العام
1949 في الرابع من شهر ابريل يعني في هذا
اليوم بالذات يعني الذي يصادف الذكرى
الرابعه والسبعين
لميثاق واشنطن
في غضون الظهر يرفع العلم في حضور رئيسي
فنلندا وكذلك وزير الخارجيه وزير الدفاع
ووزراء الخارجيه للدول الاعضاء حلف شمال
الاطلسي اكد من ان توسيع الحلف في هذا
الوقت الوجيز يعني لم يحدث هذا في السابق
بانه القمه وافقت في شهر يونيو من العام
الماضي وفنلندا تدخل تقريبا بعد اقل من
سنه الامر معطل نسبيا بسبب تركيا بالنسبه
للسويد ولكن هذه يعني لم يحدث في السابق
ان دخلت دوله ماء او انضمت دوله ما لعضويه
حلف حلف شمال الاطلسي في وقت وجيز ايضا
قال الامين العام بشكل اساسي ان ما حدث
بالنسبه لتوسعه الحلف هو رد مباشر ونتيجه
مباشره لحربي ما يسمى هو حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وقال بان الحلف ككتله قبل قبل
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بمزيد من القوات
في دول شرق اوروبا برفع مستوى الجاهزيه
وبتوسعه الحلف او بتوسيع الحلف نحو فنلندا
ومثل ما تفضلت هذه الحدود الكبيره جدا
1340 كيلو متر مشتركه اصبحت اليوم بين حلف
شمال الاطلسيين
وروسيا ولكن ربما التطورات الاخرى
سترتبط بما كيف يرتبط الامر بمستقبل هذه
الحرب الجاريه كيف ستنتهي متى ستنتهي
الاكيد ان دخول فنلندا ربما سيغذي ايضا
شهيه اوكرانيا التي ستطلب او ستؤكد مره
اخرى على طلبها العضويه الكامله في حلف
الشمال الاطلسي